[Music]
not sure the fireworks are going to be
there for katy perry and pete davidson
but tick-tock thinks they're a match
anyway
and katie's hoping pete's girl kim
kardashian isn't defended you just gotta
roll with it let us explain the singer
took a tick-tock break to mess around
with this mash filter you probably
played this game in grade school going
around in a circle to determine your
future in categories like career spouse
car and home the name is actually an
acronym for the types of homes you could
have mansion apartment shack or house
and for katie things were looking pretty
good for her in the house and car
department i want a house with a view on
rich [ __ ] avenue
[Music]
yeah up until the grammy winner got to
the romance part
[Music]
pete was randomly selected to be katie's
lover yep but minus the disgusted look
on her face katie kept things fun
offering an apology of sorts in her
caption to kim and her own beau orlando
bloom she wrote no offense kim
kardashian and orlando with a shrug
emoji i like to keep it fun now that
wasn't the only part of the filter that
surprised katie i want a yard with a
pool that you cannot yep six kids for
the singer which we're thinking might be
too many for the pop star but we do know
more kids are in the plans for her in
orlando a source recently told et
they're very in love and would love to
expand their family life is so good
that's what i am the two are already
proud parents to one-year-old daughter
daisy dove and our source says quote
their relationship is very strong and
they have parenting down they also have
figured out how to balance their busy
schedules but also make time for each
other katie is obsessed with being a mom
all the unconditional love and just the
opportunity to
see the world
uh again through like just like the most
beautiful eyes and the joy and like just
like for a new breath of life to be
breathed into
everything
it's like you get it's like you're
reborn as well oh and don't worry when
it comes to motherhood and work katie's
found a way to balance both it's
important for me to go out and also i
love traveling and
now i get to take my daughter and just
like you know i want to have that
experience once again through her eyes
[Music]
you